messieurs bonsoir c'est un cadre
prestigieux inhabituel en tout cas pour
ce journal de 20h qui va nous servir
d'environnement le sénat je pense que
vous l'avez tous reconnu
c'est vrai que nos caméras ne pénètre
pas très souvent dans cet hémicycle les
débats ils sont disons plus je trais un
petit peu moins de petites phrases un
petit peu moins d'éclat de voix qu'à
l'assemblée mais de l'avis de tous les
observateurs
un travail sérieux peut être plus
réfléchi en tout cas moins précipitée
c'est la première fois qu'un journal
sera diffusée en direct à l'occasion
d'élections sénatoriales ces élections
je pense que vous en connaissez
maintenant le fonctionnement elles ont
lieu tous les trois ans mais à chaque
fois ce n'est qu'un tiers des sénateurs
qui sont renouvelés cette fois ci tous
les départements qui vont de l'ain à
lindre plus wallis et futuna et la
polynésie
en tout 100 sièges pour 350 candidats
n'être que très peu avoir participé à
cette élection aujourd'hui mais vous
l'avez fait par personne interposée en
effet ce sont les maires les conseillers
municipaux les conseillers généraux les
députés que vous avez élu en en 76 ans
77 ans 78 qui l'ont fait ce matin et cet
après midi ils sont une cinquantaine de
milles à avoir participé au vote
vous l'avez vu au hasard des plans du
harras aux caméras disposées par
jean-luc léridon nous avons un nombre de
sénateurs qui sont avec nous et qui
participeront à une émission spéciale à
21h50 et nous avons le premier d'entre
eux le plus prestigieux c'est à dire le
président du sénat deuxième personnage
de l'état
alain poher qui nous reçoit aujourd'hui
j'arrive jusqu'à vous tout d'abord merci
de nous accueillir ce soir c'est pas
vraiment votre place aujourd'hui il faut
le dire nous sommes très heureux de vous
avoir
que cette émission ait lieu dans notre
salle de séance permettra aux français
de la mieux connaître et j'ai d'une
grande journée pour nous que ce
renouvellement d'un tiers apporte
toujours des changements et on peut dire
que les sénateurs en général leur
élection est due à leur travail efficace
le fait qu'ils sont connus comme
présidents de conseils généraux comme
maire et que c'est très bon pour nous ce
renouvellement tous les trois ans et les
changements qu'on va détailler tout à
l'heure avec un loup les scènes vous
conviennent pour l'instant moi tout me
convient comme le président je suis le
notaire et si pour l'instant je ne
participerai pas au débat politique du
tout à l'heure sans doute alors je
dirais que ce n'est pas votre vraie
place pour l'instant car vous n'êtes
plus président du sénat vous ne l'êtes
pas pendant quatre jours jusqu'à jeudi
il va y avoir la réélection du président
on peut dire dans déjà pour être
candidat c'est pour vous faire plaisir
que je me suis remis à cette place mais
enfin je me trouve bien figurez-vous
c'est comme cela je pense vous dis
depuis deux ans mais ma candidature je
dis il ya depuis 12 ans vous pensez
l'être encore pour trois ans mais je
suis sénateur depuis plus de 30 ans
venait alors je suis habitué à cette
maison nous sommes plus que quatre
l'ancien conseiller de la république la
libération évidemment merci monsieur le
président nous accueillir
pendant tout de suite voir maintenant
avec jean louis lahaye scène en passant
derrière le bureau de l'assemblée du
président ce que sont les résultats
d'aujourd'hui avec finalement la
surprise et qui a moins de surprise que
prévu alors on va commencer les
ministres les personnalités quatre des
cinq ministres du gouvernement qui
étaient candidats aujourd'hui ont été
élus au premier tour robert galley rpr
ministre de la coopération dans l'aube
et jacques pelletier udf cds secrétaire
d'état auprès du ministre de l'éducation
dans l'aisne élu au second tour
monsieur yvon bourges rpr ministre de la
défense dans l'ille-et-vilaine et marc
bécam rpr secrétaire d'état aux
collectivités locales dans le finistère
le battu vers le bas tu sais marcel
cavaliers secrétaire d'état au logement
qui se présentait en haute garonne
alors maintenant voyons un peu dans le
bétail les surprises dans l'aisne dans
l'aisne trois élus au premier tour
jacques pelletier secrétaire d'état
ancien sénateur donc je les dis jacques
braconnier sénateurs sortants rpr
paul girot sénateurs sortants udf à
noter que maurice brugnon députés qui se
présentait pour le parti socialiste a
lui été battu dans l'allier jean cluzel
sénateur sortant conseiller général de
moulins cds réélu à l'issue d'un
ballottage difficile dans l'ardèche
henri tort député ancien ministre a été
élu dans les ardennes la majorité se
maintient rené tine en île maurice blin
ont été réélus ils sont tous les deux
udf cds territoire de belfort michel
dreyfus schmidt ancien député ps est élu
au détriment du sénateur sortant bernard
talons rpr dans le calvados
trois sortants réélus philippe de
bourgoin président du groupe
républicains et indépendants au sénat
réélu donc jacques bécourt de sacs et
jean marie giraud sénateur sortant lui
aussi en charente en charente
la surprise c'est le fait que pierre
marcil à six sénateurs sortants
non-inscrits est été battus
charente-maritime trois sièges à
pourvoir trois radicaux de gauche josy
moinet stéphane bonduelle et michel
rigaud en corrèze henri beyle cours
maire d'ussel suppliante jacques chirac
est élu georges mouly ancien maire de
tulle sans étiquette a été élu il faut
remarquer que marcel champex sénateur
socialiste sortant et président du
groupe socialiste au sénat a été battu
faut dire aussi
il faut dire aussi que les communistes
avaient maintenu leurs candidats au
deuxième tour dans le doubs robert
schwint maire de besançon ps réélu le
président edgar faure ancien ministre
député divers majorité a été élu ainsi
que louis souvet divers majorité le
monsieur jacques henry est sénateur
sortant indépendants ne se représentait
pas dans leur élection de rené tomasini
dès le premier tour dans le finistère
donc marc bécam secrétaire d'état à
l'intérieur maire de quimper élu en
haute garonne
quatre sièges à pourvoir quatre élus
socialistes
monsieur marcel cavaillé donc je vous le
disais a été battu a signalé qu entre
les deux tours pierre baudis apparentés
p&r maire de toulouse avait posé sa
candidature dans l'hérault dans
l'hérault des fêtes de monsieur pierre
brousse ancien sénateur ancien
secrétaire d'état ancien maire de
béziers radical socialiste enfin dans
l'ille-et-vilaine il
bourges vous disais maire de dinard a
été élu ministre de la défense ainsi que
louis la forêt ceni fait jean madelin et
marcel données entre les deux tours
françois le douarec député rpr s'était
retiré de la compétition
merci jean louis daniel brel on peut
commencer tout de suite une esquisse
pronostics pour l'avenir et un certain
nombre de commentaires en tout cas pour
l'immédiat car nous avons tous les
résultats et puis votre initiative et
une esquisse parce que nous avons quand
même pas encore tous les chiffres
l'affrontement entre le parti communiste
et le parti socialiste c'est sûr s'est
traduit dans les résultats et le parti
socialiste notamment au lieu d'engranger
15 sièges supplémentaires et bien en
engrange que neuf
les communistes sont en partie
responsables de cet état de chose car il
avait à trois reprises adressé des
avertissements aux socialistes et
notamment demandé la formation de listes
communes dans les côtes du nord le parti
communiste qui n'avait qu'un sénateur
sortant dans les bouches du rhône qui a
été réélu et qu'ils n'engrangent aucun
résultat annie aujourd'hui ses menaces à
exécution et ses candidats se sont
maintenues au deuxième tour dans six
départements les courbes du nord le
finistère la corrèze la dordogne la
creuse et le doubs cette mésentente a
permis à la majorité dans des
départements réputé difficile et bien de
l'emporter alors on vous a dit que dans
l'allier notamment monsieur plus elle
l'avait emporté mais sont seconds
monsieur rabineau est passé également
est par exemple dans le doubs où les
communistes également se sont maintenues
le président edgar faure est élu au
deuxième tour et il a gagné un siège
supplémentaire à la majorité alors ce
coup de semonce aura-t-il des
prolongements lors des prochaines
élections partielles législatives et
même des présidentielles il est très
clair en tout cas que le parti
communiste entend réduire à tout prix
l'écart qui le sépare du parti
socialiste ce que monsieur parmentier le
sénateur socialiste dans les couloirs
disait après tout à l'heure la politique
de la terre brûlée ce qui peut également
inquiété à juste titre monsieur françois
mitterrand il faut aussi observer que le
rpr enregistre un gain notable parmi
lesquels plus j'ai remis
istres il avait six sortants et il a
aujourd'hui 12 élus l'intergroupe de
l'udf retrouve si on additionne ses
composantes à peu près le nombre de ses
sièges
peut-être un peu plus mais il est encore
trop tôt pour le dire
le parti qui fait figure de victime ce
soir c'est le ceni qui avait seize
membres et qui ce soir n'a plus
suffisamment de membres pour fermer un
groupe à moins qu'un groupe de la
majorité ne lui paraître quelques-uns de
ses sénateurs alors la majorité faut le
noter aussi s'est dans l'ensemble bien
comportés lorsqu'il y avait des listes
d'union et monsieur le douarec dans
l'île vilaine qui faisait cavalier seul
et bien s'en est aperçu à ses dépens
quatre ministres sur cinq ayant été élu
il y aura un remaniement ministériel et
à sept mois des présidentielles
évidemment cela peut être intéressant
d'autant plus que deux postes importants
dans se trouvait vacant de la défense et
la coopération
enfin je vous le rappelle il y aura
cette élection partielle dans le doubs
l'ardèche la gironde la dordogne la leur
et l'aveyron où monsieur faron vous le
savez est devenu le créateur a bien
merci daniel en amont ce sont les
présidentielles qui nous intéressent
directement est ce qu'on peut déjà faire
des projections et dire comme certains
le disent dans ses couloirs du sénat en
ce moment ça veut dire que le pc jouent
le jeu et décide de se présenter assez
souvent contre le psg et de
l'embarrasser au maximum c'est une c'est
une possibilité on ne peut évidemment
pas penser que le parti communiste est
seulement eu un mouvement d'humeur
dans son cas c'est une stratégie
délibérée ça peut n'être qu'un coup de
semonce pour obtenir du parti socialiste
les congestions car il faut se souvenir
que dans le passé le parti communiste a
souvent fait des concessions retirer ses
candidats même s'ils n'obtenaient rien
il fait là dans certains cas mais pas
dans tout ce n'est pas dans tous les
hauts risques de faire élire un candidat
de la majorité par conséquent je crois
que depuis ce soir l'éventualité selon
laquelle le parti communiste pourrait ne
pas recommander à ceux qui ont voté pour
son candidat au premier tour de reporter
leurs suffrages sur le candidat
socialiste s'il arrive en tête
à beaucoup plus de crédit dignité reste
que ses électeurs ne lui appartiennent
pas à plus forte raison quand il s'agira
du corps électoral et qui a là une
différence appréciable entre les déjà il
semble que dans certains départements au
second tour les électeurs communistes
n'ai pas tout suivi est permis ici ou là
l'élection du socialiste dont une partie
en tout cas pour la première fois sa une
crédibilité ça rappelle un épisode qui
est vieux de 12 ans et que monsieur
polaire connais bien c'est lorsque le
parti communiste avait recommandé
l'abstention lorsque monsieur power et l
adversaire de georges pompidou je crois
que cette éventualité acquis un peu de
crédibilité sur le bonnet blanc blanc
bonnet blanc alors justement parlons de
monsieur bonnet de mise de l'intérieur
qui a fait une petite déclaration tout à
l'heure au ministre l'a d'ailleurs là où
était jean michel mercurol ne l'ont donc
entendre cette déclaration sur les
élections sénatoriales du ministre
l'intérieur christian bonnet il convient
s'agissant de la haute assemblée de se
montrer extrêmement prudent en ce qui
concerne les classifications
c'est seulement en effet je l'avais déjà
dit il y a trois ans au moment de
l'inscription des nouveaux sénateurs un
groupe politique qu'il sera possible de
tirer les conséquences précises du
scrutin d'aujourd'hui
mais d'ores et déjà trois observations
peuvent être faites en premier lieu
l'opposition ne tire pas le bénéfice
qu'elle espérait des élections de 1977
elle n'enregistre en effet qu'un gain de
six sièges alors que je le rappelle 10
sièges supplémentaires avaient été
créées par la loi de 1976
en second lieu les formations qui
soutiennent le gouvernement gagnant 4
sièges gardent une large majorité au
sénat
enfin sur les cinq membres du
gouvernement qui étaient candidats
à 4-3 rpr et un udf ont été élus
j'imagine que c'est pour pour de
monsieur bonnet seront commentés tout à
l'heure par nos invités y seront donc à
21h50 nos interlocuteurs pour un
magazine spécial toujours en direct de
cet hémicycle du sénat quand maintenant
voir le reste de l'actualité est tout
d'abord à l'étranger toujours la guerre
entre l'iran et l'irak qui retient
l'attention
on ne peut pas parler de répit ce soir
après une semaine de style it et les
irakiens ont au contraire accentué leurs
offensives
fou de paris les communiqués de victoire
des uns les autres ils sont la plupart
du temps démenti
dans la minute qui suit pendant une
partie de l'après-midi terran qui
craignaient un rêve de l'aviation de
bagdad a été mis en alerte rouge
philippe rochot l'armée irakienne a peut
être retrouvé un second souffle ses
blindés ont aujourd'hui dépassé
la petite ville frontalière de brasseurs
shirin 20 km à l'intérieur du territoire
iranien
bagdad affirme aussi que dans la
province du khouzistan au sud elles
encerclent la ville pétrolière de
paroisse qui compte près de 50000
habitants et se trouve ainsi à 60 km à
l'intérieur de l'iran l'état-major de
téhéran a démenti la nouvelle
mais les seules images que nous recevons
comme celle ci nous viennent uniquement
de la télévision irakienne et il est
difficile de vérifier la percée
irakiennes n'est en tout cas pas
suffisante pour placer bagdad en état de
supériorité lors d'éventuelles
négociations et l'irak est décidé à
poursuivre son ascension bagdad affirme
même que le tiers de ses effectifs
seulement est engagé dans la bataille
la rance de l'armée irakienne se
confirme pourtant de jour en jour face à
une armée iranienne éclaté et affaiblie
ces soldats irakiens qui ont fait hier
leur entrée dans la petite ville
frontalière de brasseur kirin ont
affirmé qu'il venait libérer la minorité
arabe d'iran persécuté par cros mines
ils savent que dans cette offensive il
dispose de l'appui de la majorité des
pays arabes les l'irak n'est pas pressé
de négocier dans ces conditions la
médiation de la médiation des uns et des
autres c'est très ardues aussi bien pour
yasser arafat que pour le général zia le
chef de l'état pakistanais
les deux hommes ont d'ailleurs rencontré
ce matin le président bani sadr le
général zia s'est ensuite rendu à bagdad
et il n'arrivera peut-être pas comme on
l'avait prévu à paris cette nuit il n'y
aura donc pas de rencontre avec le
président giscard d'estaing le président
pakistanais zia ici à téhéran avec le
président bani sadr a donc passé hier et
aujourd'hui à essayer de convaincre les
belligérants qu'une négociation
même mauvaise vaut mieux qu'une bonne
guerre mandaté par la conférence
islamique dont il est aussi le président
le général zia a expliqué à son
homologue iranien bani sadr que l'irak a
attaqué parce qu'elle avait des
revendications territoriales sur le cosy
ce temps habité par des arabes et
qu'elle avait voulu récupérer la partie
de la voie d'eau le chacal arabe qu'elle
revendique aussi mais le général zia qui
aux yeux des irakiens le dictateur qui a
fait pendre son prédécesseur ali bhutto
et qui de surcroît est l'ami des
saoudiens
a pu convaincre ses interlocuteurs qui
réaffirme ne vouloir accepter aucune
solution négociée
tant qu'il y aura un soldat irakien sur
leur sol une position qui n'est pas
celle du président irakien saddam
hussein
le général zia de veracruz peu après à
bagdad où sa mission a reçu un accueil
favorable et tout à l'heure le
département d'état américain a mis une
nouvelle fois en garde moscou contre
toute tentative d'intervention militaire
en iran visiblement ce sont les
installations pétrolières des vins et
les autres qui sont essentiellement la
cible le président banny salon tout à
l'heure n'excluait pas le recours à une
tentative de sabotage de ses propres
installations
si jamais les irakiens prenait
définitivement à badens alors pour ce
qui est maintenant des conséquences en
occident tendrait giraud des tout à
l'heure l'invité du club de la presse de
europe 1 et il a bien entendu commenter
les récents événements et leur poids sur
l'approvisionnement pétrolier de la
france il s'est montré assez rassurant
par nos stocks
nous pouvons tenir quinze mois une
interruption totale au moins quinze mois
une interruption totale de
l'approvisionnement irakien si l'on veut
apprécier plus complètement la situation
peut également rappeler que
l'approvionnement irakien est du même
ordre de grandeur de ce que représente l
approvisionnement iraniens aux moments
la crise iranienne est née à l'époque
les stocks étaient plutôt bas dans le
monde entier actuellement ils sont
beaucoup plus importants et vous savez
que à la veille de la crise on avait
constaté un excédent de production
d'environ 2 millions de barils/jour
contre
alors que l'irak représente à peu près 3
million et demi de barils jour et on
voit donc en principe cette crise se
présente internationalement plus
facilement que ne se présenter la
disparition de la provision de l'iranien
en son temps bien entendu les
circonstances politiques sont beaucoup
plus complexes dans le golfe et il faut
donc dire tout cela avec infiniment de
prudence sur les prix naturellement pour
l'instant il n'y a aucun aucune
modification des prises officielle et il
n'y a aucun indice qui lie année puisque
avant même la crise une tendance allait
plutôt à la maîtrise de ses prix parce
qu'ils estimaient que la récession
économique mondiale était déjà bien
suffisante
donc je ne pense pas qu'il y ait ce
levier là par contre il est probable que
nous allons assister à quelques a
follement sur des marchés spot et il
faudra éviter que ceux-ci une porte
contagion en un giro qui par ailleurs a
beaucoup été interrogé sur le problème
le nucléaire français c'est pour moi
l'occasion de vous rappeler ce rendez
vous que vous avez demain avec question
de temps à 20h35 je suis une audition
publique sur le thème des surgénérateurs
donc je pense vous commencez à bien
connaître les tenants et les
aboutissants c'est une option publique
ça veut dire que des français
interrogeront des députés sur le
problème sur ses atouts et sur ces
risques alors ces français seront une
douzaine ses députés seront quatre ils
seront épaulés
quant au questionnaire par louis blériot
georges leclercq et pour europe 1
charles villeneuve
ces députés seront en pierre messmer
pour le rpr bernard deschamps pour le pc
arthur pêche pour l'udf et paul quilès
pour le ps donc le rendez vous demain
question de temps 20h35 les policiers
allemands ont fait vite ils sont déjà
persuadés que l'auteur de l'attentât est
bien parmi les victimes de cet attentat
effroyable de munich
il s'agit donc d'un membre du groupe
hoffman au d'extrême droite dont six
membres vient d'être passée placé sous
mandat de dépôt michel meyer a suivi de
bout en bout
enquête sur un attentat qui a déjà fait
douze morts et 200 blessés
bah quand regard fiévreux allure
martiale
le néo fureur hoffman est un nostalgique
de la ss du troisième reich et de hitler
ses troupes 80 membres dont deux femmes
on le considère comme la tête de
l'attentât de munich où l'un de ses
complices blanc a été découvert parmi
les douze morts déchiquetés par la bombe
il s'agit d'un étudiant en géologie de
22 ans alors qu'il est hoffman a été
arrêté ainsi qu'une vingtaine de ses
amis jusqu'en janvier dernier
ils organisaient des manoeuvres para
militaires qui étaient jugés plus
grotesque que dangereuse dans la mesure
où ces engins de guerre venait du tas de
ferraille et où les armes d'exercice
avait été banalisé
malgré diverses razia les autorités
bavaroises n'avait jamais rien pu
retenir contre hoffman de son côté la
presse avait épinglé le groupe hoffman
parmi les curiosités risible de
l'allemagne évoquait avec des clins
d'oeil
sa manie de jouer au petit soldat il a
fallu attendre le début de cette année
pour que bones perdre patience et
prononce l'interdiction et la
dissolution du groupe néo-nazi cela un
peu contre la volonté du gouvernement de
bavière de franz josef strauss ce qui
m'est rentrée h 30 précisément situation
difficile pour les autorités bavaroises
en effet hoffman et ses adeptes étaient
des fous et d'égout phoque beaucoup plus
que des éléments dangereux votre attente
a heureusement sans victime celui
perpétré cette nuit contre un bureau
bâtiment israeli qu'en fait à paris une
synagogue du 15e arrondissement
l'attentât condamné par tout le monde
politique ce soir de laurent fabius pour
le ps à pascal gauchon pour le parti
forces nouvelles ont régalé à interroger
le grand rabbin de paris
une personne a été atteint on a très
nettement vu les impacts des balles sur
les vitraux de la synagogue et c'est un
pacte se retrouve de l'autre côté de la
synagogue à une dizaine de mètres
d'autres synagogue ont déjà vu un
certain nombre d'inscriptions
antisémites ici même il n'y a pas eu
d'inscriptions depuis de très nombreuses
années
je peux même constater avec tristesse
que pendant la guerre cette synagogue
n'a pas été touché par les allemands et
que maintenant
dv les auteurs de ces attentats cherche
à nous intimider autour de vous comment
la la communauté juive réagi après les
événements de cette nuit je peux vous
dire que nous n'avons jamais eu autant
de monde à la synagogue qu'à l'office de
ce matin au secours catholique vous
connaissez mais je pense que vous
connaissez surtout pour son action
entreprise à l'étranger
il faut savoir que cet organisme
charitable s'occupe également beaucoup
des déshérités français et notamment des
chômeurs dont la condition est la plus
dramatique 94 % de ceux qui accueillent
le secours catholique ne dispose d'aucun
revenu pour vivre
or derrière le chômeur lui-même il est
bien souvent sa famille avec tous les
cas douloureux et les problèmes que cela
peut comporter un reportage dans régaler
traduisant froid de statistiques les
chiffres du secours catholique exprime
une réelle misère 38% de ses chômeurs ne
peuvent acheter des vêtements 37% ne
peuvent payer gaz électricité et
chauffage 21% leur loyer et vivent donc
sous le risque permanent d'une expulsion
les chômeurs en état de survie ne sont
pas une minorité
le secours catholique ne rencontre
qu'une faible partie de ces exclus les
plus démunis ont poussé la porte des
foyers 45% d'entre eux avaient fait ça
m'arrivait de pas mangé pendant une
semaine
mais ça fait
ça s'est passé comment et où
mais ici à paris depuis depuis quinze
jours depuis que je suis arrivé la
première fois vont bien salée puisque
j'avais 150 francs poche
bon ben je pouvais quand même dormir à
l'hôtel et puis mangé un peu vain bon
après j'ai traîné droite à gauche pas de
travail
bon en attendant je mangeais pas cette
enquête effectuée par le secours
catholique portait sur des cendres 79
pour l'année 80 l'organisation pense
être amené à traiter plus de 25 mille
cas désespérés
au delà des chiffres il est des choses
difficilement quantifiable sans
ressources le chômeur devient souvent un
exclu il perd ses relations vite isolé
se sent inutile encore un chiffre
extrait de cette enquête
pour 19% des familles le chômage a
entraîné la désunion
les jeunes ont quitté la famille les
pères ont abandonné leurs foyers
cantonné couple est parent qui travaille
la femme est au chômage évidemment sa
carte irda foyer mais quand une femme se
retrouve seul avec deux petits-enfants
et bien ce tragique parce que ne
trouvera pas de place où les mettre je
ne peux pas me permettre de payer une
nourrice agrée ça coûterait cher environ
1800 francs par mois pour deux enfants
je n'ai pas les moyens de le faire donc
je ne peux pas travailler puisque vos
problèmes financiers sont allés
quelquefois vous obliger à faire
attention
oui je suis tout le baratin et moi je ne
mange pas les midis je mange que le soir
c'est tout pas de sortie pas de cinéma
pas de coiffeur pas des vêtements pas de
coquetterie nous tous et les recherches
d'emploi il faut les payer parce qu'on a
lorsqu'on écrit une lettre il faut mais
des timbres pour les réponses il faut
payer aussi les communications
téléphoniques
il faut se déplacer aussi faut prendre
le métro et aux ti-cats de francs 50
savez c'est plusieurs fois le trajet
aller retour
c'est pas possible je ne peux même pas
mal de choses sur ce que je n'ai pas les
moyens je deviens pas chez tout sur ma
fille passe quelque chose aux enfants
sont très chères sont plus chers que
pour les adultes et j'en ai assez
d'aller mendier tous les mois au ps vous
comprenez si je faisais pas une solution
j'ai envie de travailler je me sens
capable de travailler puisque nous
pensons tout le monde qu'il vous donne
peuvent preuve ce monde s'est tu que
c'est épouvantable ce temps on ne pense
pas plier des gens qui vivent
marginalement ne pense pas qu'il y ait
des gens qui sont au chômage parce que
les gens sont terriblement égoïste et
gens pensent qu'à eux mêmes mais reflux
regarder autour de soi
il ya déjà malheureux il n'y a pas que
moi dans ce cas je pense qu'il ya
d'autres femmes qui vivent ce que je vis
moi je pense qu'il est important que ça
se sache que il y a quelque chose à
faire mais qui doit s'en charger qui
doit le faire
madame pelletier mais c'est jusqu'à
destin monsieur baba sylla prétend que
les gens qui ne veulent pas qu'ils
travaillent qui ne travaillent pas sont
des gens qui ne veulent pas travailler
ce n'est pas vrai qu'on nous donne la
possibilité de faire garder nos enfants
ne travailleront c'est ça l'essentiel
je crois qu'il s'agit d'un reportage et
témoignages accusateurs tout à l'heure
un forcené qui s'était barricadé toute
la journée à saint gilles les bois près
de paris avec sa femme et ses quatre
enfants a tué son épouse avant d'être
maîtrisé par les forces de le tiercé du
jour il se disputait à longchamp et si
vous avez suivi les conseils de key west
mais vous pouvez vous attendre à une
bonne surprise elle l'a donné en quatre
chevaux mais pas dans l'ordre
alors le vrai le bon celui qu'il fallait
jouer c'est le 14 le 3 et le 4 pire est
le commentaire la course s'imaginent que
vous voyez en tête du peloton
actuellement sera victime de son
tempérament trop généreux
tire beaucoup et philippe paquet son
jockey n'a pas réussi à la cacher or il
est impossible à longchamp de gagner en
menant de bout en bout surtout sur 2400
mètres à l'entrée de la ligne droite
elle lâché prise regardez c'est le
numéro 8
c'est maintenant les délices et au à
nous et qui même dans alcon du vent
lierre napolitain a mis à benoîte l'aris
tonique et belval au milieu un million
droitards historique ni cas qui a l'air
décidé aujourd'hui lance sa pointe de
vitesse et se rapproche de la tête
c'est la casaque rouge noir top blanche
au milieu bel vac le kazakh des stocks
loi en fait autant à l'extérieur au à
nous et qui semble garder le meilleur là
ce qui est assez éloquent et pyrénées au
sud du massif central et des alpes le
temps orageux persistera et donnera
quelques ondées orageuses
votre dernier journal sera présenté à
23h40 par gérard holtz demain antenne
2010 notre invité sera un veau un veau
en chair et en os si possible sans
hormones et il est évident que ce
problème des hormones et du traitement
niveau sera au centre de nos
conversations et nos préoccupations à
12h45
demain et puis je vous rappelle que à
21h50 c'est à dire juste après
l'émission qui va suivre ce journal vous
avez à nouveau rendez vous avec le sénat
un débat réunira tous ceux qui sont
passionnés par ce débat c'est à dire
tous les groupes du politique du sénat
mais aussi rené rémond pour les
commentaires noël copain daniel brême
jean-louis le scène alain poher le
président du sénat est un ensemble
d'invités je vous donne donc ce
rendez-vous 21h50
tout de suite après l'émission qui va
suivre bonsoir à tous